there seems to be a big gap between what
public health officials in the United
Kingdom and England in particular are
saying about e-cigarettes and what we're
saying here in the US what do you think
explains that discrepancy both England
and some scientists here are looking at
the best science and we see the same
thing it's a way less harmful than
cigarettes and they can and do help
smokers switch if they can't quit I
think there's a very strong concern here
that is more focused on both teens and
the evil of the big tobacco industry
that tends to distort the science and
lead to exaggerated harms and omission
of benefits
so you're saying researchers are coming
to that conclusion even though the FDA
has not yet reviewed it and made that
determination yes I think that's correct
the science has actually gotten
extremely strong especially in the last
three to four years and we've been
following it closely probably the most
powerful study is a randomized trial
which is the gold standard that showed
that in 12-month follow-up C cigarettes
doubled the successful quit rate among
smokers compared to nicotine replacement
therapy which is fda-approved but it
takes a long time for the government to
essentially make those kind of strong
statements so what do we know right now
about the risks of e-cigarettes relative
to cigarettes I think what we know for
sure is that based on all the biomarkers
of harm that we know from cigarettes
that they are far fewer and far lower in
a cigarettes than cigarettes that
statement can't be made because you
can't judge the long-term risk of
benefit and that's true that we don't
know the long-term risks and benefits
and we won't for 50 years but we know
enough now from the science of the
biomarkers of harm especially cancer
that show us that there are so few of
those chemicals and at such low levels
that e-cigarettes are biologically much
less harmful in terms of exposures
they're not harmless
but they are dramatically less harmful
if the truth is his plane is that what
do you think explains the alarm right
now around e-cigarettes well I think
there is concern and it's legitimate
that teens are using them at much higher
rates and there is a concern about
nicotine and nicotine addiction even
though nicotine itself doesn't cause the
cancer heart disease or lung ailments
that cigarettes do it's the smoke and
the carbon monoxide nicotine is not
harmless and there is a concern that
teens who use it might get addicted and
then go on to cigarette smoking but the
evidence doesn't really support that at
a level that we ordered panic about it
when you think about a cigarette and
what kills you in a cigarette what comes
to mind I'm thinking tar carbon monoxide
correct the tourism is a catch-all term
for the essentially junk in the in the
burning of tobacco and that includes 69
known human cancer-causing chemicals of
which 10 or 12 are very potent and we
know what those are and therefore we can
look for them in the blood of people who
have switched to e-cigarettes and the
FDA's own study of that which is
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine confirms that our forty-five
biomarkers only 12 were detectable in
e-cigarettes and of those none were at
levels that approach those of cigarettes
so the biomarkers are very clear that
there are less of them and of those that
are there they are much less harmful if
every American smokers switched to an
e-cigarette mm-hmm would public health
benefit I think there's no question
public health would benefit dramatically
if everybody switched completely to
e-cigarettes and we made cigarettes
obsolete that would also solve the teen
problem because we wouldn't be afraid of
the gateway to cigarettes if nobody
wanted cigarettes anymore
and our study suggested that if 10% of
current smokers switched completely to
e-cigarettes every year for the next ten
years so 10 percent a year for 10 years
means a hundred percent switch within 10
years
we'd save as much as six to seven
million lives who otherwise would die
from cigarette smoking and 87 million
quality life years would be gained from
that scenario of switching completely in
ten years to e-cigarettes so what do you
think then of the hundreds of cases of
lung disease mysterious lung disease
tied to vaping so the common sense
explanation of that is it's a sudden
outbreak that happened ten years after
cigarettes came on the market and I
think all the evidence we've seen from
the FDA and the CDC reports is that
these cases are people who bought
marijuana oils on the street made it
either illegally or or in a sort of a
street version like a street drug a
dirty street drug I we haven't seen a
single case that a commercially made
legitimate a cigarette that smokers are
using has caused any of these illnesses
and I would say for smokers they should
not be scared by what they're seeing and
that e-cigarettes should still be used
instead of cigarettes if they've already
switched why the skepticism you think
from other researchers the fear is that
this is a Trojan horsed by the big
tobacco companies and since they've done
some things in the past that are very
untrustworthy I think people are very
reluctant to give credit for the fact
that someone could switch to an
e-cigarette even though the science is
incontrovertible the the emotion of the
disgust with the industry I think makes
people forget that we've got 38 million
smokers that we have to help and we're
here to help those smokers it sounds
like you're saying that we are fighting
a cigarette with the fury we wish we had
fought cigarettes with decades ago yes
and I think we've forgotten that a
hundred and twenty years ago the
disruptive technology was the cigarette
rolling machine that literally caused
this epidemic of lung cancer and other
diseases and now we have an opportunity
a hundred
20 years later to get rid of the
cigarette with a new technology that
delivers nicotine in a very satisfying
way without the major harms of burning
tobacco if we lose this opportunity I
think we will have blown the single
biggest public health opportunity we've
ever had in a hundred and twenty years
to get rid of cigarettes and replace
them with a much safer form of nicotine
for everybody